he's zelich he's everywhere from World
War one to World War two to the Cold War
to the new frontier I have Nicol SP with
reason TV and today we're talking with
David Nassau he's a historian and his
most recent book is the patriarchy it's
a biography of Joseph Kennedy the father
of JFK RFK and Teddy Kennedy David
thanks for talking with us
so glad to be here what brought you to
the Joseph Kennedy project the Kennedys
thank you the Kennedys came to me yes
kenny's came to me and they said we want
you to do a biography of her father I
said I can't I'm working on something
else Kennedys don't take no for an
answer
six months later I got a call from
Senator Kennedy went to Washington to
talk to him I said to them you don't
want me to do this because I'm gonna
find stuff that the family is not gonna
like and he said no everybody knows
about Gloria Swanson and my father
wasn't an anti-semite and whatever you
find is gonna be better than what's out
there and and that's true I think what
drove them was that there would be a
tacit agreement since 1952 when Jack ran
for the Senate that Joe would be sent
into exile and whatever charges came up
against him the family would not answer
and Joe would not answer and I think the
family felt a tad bit guilty that no one
had been you know no one had provided
any defense of the man or any true
historical portrait so well let's talk
about the anti-semitism when Joe Kennedy
particularly when he was a he was the
ambassador of the u.s. to England to the
court of st. James during World War two
he was pro-nazi or he was certainly
friendly towards the Nazi and
undercutting various American efforts
and he was anti-semitic wasn't he he was
not pro Nazi Lynne Berg was pro-nazi
they're a bunch of others who were
pro-nazi Kennedy was not he was anti-war
and he believed the only way to stop the
war was to make a deal with Hitler
anything was better than war
therefore give hitler 80% of what he
wants why was he so anti-war which was
not an unpopular position for Americans
to have it know from 1938 to 1942 vast
majority of Americans wanted nothing to
do with the war they did not want for a
second time in a generation to bail out
the British Empire certainly Irish
Americans didn't want to do that and
Kennedy was an Irish American he
believed also that if we went into war
or if the British went into war the
fragile economy that was just recovering
from the depression would be smacked
down in a way it would never recover
capitalism would be threatened his
fortune would be threatened democracy
would be threatened but certainly what
he said over and over and over again is
look what's happening in Britain in 1940
from 1939 certainly from 40 on certainly
once Churchill becomes Prime Minister
free-market economy in Britain is it's
over he's essentially making the same
argument that Friedrich Hayek made in
the road to serfdom that economic
planning is going to lead to a ultimate
takeover of the economy he wouldn't go
that far
economic planning isn't okay regulation
of runaway capitalism when runaway
bankers of markets and he was the first
head of the what of the security and he
outlawed every trick that he had used to
make his millions of dollars insider
trading so in short but he did not want
economic trading he believed in free
markets he believes strongly in free
markets he believed that you can't fight
a war with free markets if you fight a
controlled market if you fight a
dictatorship the only way to win is to
replicate those structures Brig net his
antagonism towards war his
non-interventionism into the 50s because
he also at that point he seemed to be
much more in a cold war context he would
have been seen as an appeaser
of the Soviet Union as well did that
stem from the same worries absolutely
number one he believed
that the American economy could be
self-sufficient that we didn't need to
trade with Europe we needed to trade
with South America number two every
dollar sent to Europe to support
European troops or to send American boys
to be stationed in Germany was a dollar
loss number three the more we became an
imperial military power the more money
would be withdrawn from building
American infrastructure and American
manufacturing this disabuse us of the
long-running canard that he was a
bootlegger I mean he made money off the
liquor business but he was not it's not
that he was a bootleg one of the great
examples of American myth making there
were seven eight FBI investigations of
Joe Kennedy lots of stuff got into those
FBI reports but nothing about
bootlegging it is only in the late 60s
in the early 70s when conspiracy
theorists tried to tie the assassination
to the mob and then the mob to the
Kennedy family that these rumors start
to surface but he did make money from
liquor right he yeah he anticipated the
end of prohibition the guy is a
brilliant brilliant a brilliant
businessman he knows number one that
soon as Roosevelt's inaugurated
prohibition is ending number two that
you can make gin overnight in New Jersey
but fine Scotch which Americans have
always had a taste for has to come from
Britain has to be imported as soon as
the elections over he gathers up Jimmy
Roosevelt president's son goes to
Britain makes a deal with the top
distiller to import exclusively the best
American scotch sets up Somerset
importers which brings in I mean it's a
cash cow for the family until Jack runs
for office and then what's the long
measure of Joseph Kennedy you know what
can we learn from his life because he's
a conflicted person there are as many
ugly things about him as anything that
might be admirable
it's an understanding of 20th century
history 20th century US history that we
otherwise don't get an Irish Catholic
kid from Boston who struggles to get
inside but always views what's going on
in the establishment with a jaundiced
eye so we can look again at World War
one the stock market boom in the 1920s
at Hollywood he's a participant in
Hollywood when we go from silence to
talkies at the New Deal he's a new
dealer on the inside but skeptical much
of New Deal policy he's the ambassador
to Great Britain
he's zelich he's everywhere from World
War one to World War two to the Cold War
to the new frontier and if you follow
his perspective if you look at the world
as he looks at it your understanding of
20th century history is enormous Lee
expanded you know World War two is not
Tom Brokaw's you know Greatest
Generation it's not a battle to end evil
there's much more to it than that I want
to thank David Nassau author of the
patriarchy it's a biography of Joseph
Kennedy for talking with reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie
you